ok google
ich fühle mich nicht so gut ich habe
bauchschmerzen ein bisschen
kopfschmerzen sagt gestern was fehlt mir
[Musik]
lange wartezeiten beim arzt
regelmäßige fehldiagnosen und ständig
überwiesen werden krank sein macht es
schon keinen spaß aber wenn das
gesundheitssystem einem nicht helfen
kann ist das richtig gefährlich laut aok
starben 2014 19.000 menschen durch
vermeidbare behandlungsfehler zeit dass
technologie uns hier unter die arme
greift wie kann uns künstliche
intelligenz in der medizin helfen
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
auf doktor watson und abonniert gerne
den kanal um kein neues video zu
verpassen
künstliche intelligenz wird häufig als
wundermittel für unsere probleme
dargestellt
und ja ich kann schon einige wirklich
beeindruckende dinge vollbringen aber
oft sind es gerade die langweiligen und
eintönigen aufgaben für die ki super
geeignet ist wie bei selbstfahrenden
autos gilt und wir menschen machen
schnell flüchtigkeitsfehler werden müde
oder gelangweilt in der medizin passiert
das zum beispiel beim einscannen und
speichern endloser bild und text dateien
oder dem vermessen von tumoren beides
können bilderkennung softwares mit hilfe
von ki übernehmen
das entlastet das pflegepersonal und
soll so mehr zeit für
zwischenmenschliche kommunikation
ermöglichen ein faktor der in der
heilung übrigens oft unterschätzt wird
ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit und
zuneigung helfen vielen menschen schon
dabei sich besser zu fühlen und die
heilung zu beschleunigen ähnliches thema
ihr kennt das vielleicht euch geht's
nicht so gut also google gehen mal
schnell ein paar euro symptome kann es
schon mal fehler denn lauschen doktor
google habt ihr meist krebs pest und
cholera gleichzeitig und sollte
eigentlich längst tot sein
ärzte raten aus gutem grund davon ab
sich selber über das internet zu
diagnostizieren
stattdessen könnte man in zukunft mit
chats schreiben erhält ist ein startup
aus berlin das mit künstlicher
intelligenz herausfinden will was ihr
wirklich fehlt und dich dann direkt an
die passende fachärztin oder den
passenden facharzt weiterleitet ohne
dass man erst lange wartezeiten beim
hausarzt über sich ergehen lassen muss
gerade auf dem land wo akuter
ärztemangel herrscht wäre das eine
wichtige entlastung aber kann noch
deutlich mehr an der uni heidelberg wird
gerade daran geforscht wie man schwarzen
hautkrebs besser diagnostizieren kann in
einer studie von 2018 wurden 100.000
bilder von muttermalen und den
dazugehörigen diagnosen in ein
neuronales netz gefüttert welches sich
dann mit 58 dermatologen und
dermatologen aus 17 ländern messen
musste den experten und der software
wurden jeweils 100 bisher unbekannte
bilder von muttermalen gezeigt 20 bilder
zeigten bösartige melanome 80 waren
harmlose muttermale und das ergebnis war
verblüffend
der computer schlug bei 19 der 20
melanom alarm 95 trefferquote die
berufserfahrenen dermatologen schafften
nur 86 6 prozent gab man den ärzten
zusätzliche informationen wie alter und
geschlecht der patienten dann kamen sie
auf 88,9 prozent immer noch nicht so gut
wie die bilderkennung des neuronalen
netz andersherum war es allerdings bei
den harmlosen muttermalen hier war die
ki in 29 fällen zu voreilig und hat
krebs diagnostiziert der keiner war
die experten machten das allerdings auch
und zwar 20 x und man könnte
argumentieren dass es wesentlich fataler
ist jemanden mit krebs nach hause zu
schicken als jemanden ohne krebs in
behandlung zu geben
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass so eine
software in zukunft ein super assistent
wäre ein arzt könnte sich mit einer
kamera und der entsprechenden software
direkt eine zweite meinung einholen oder
wird vielleicht auch stellen aufmerksam
gemacht die eher harmlos fand die aber
vielleicht doch gar nicht so harmlos
sind übrigens gibt es das auch heute
schon als app fürs handy einfach
einscannen und nach wenigen sekunden
schätzt der algorithmus wie gefährlich
diese stelle ist ein besuch beim arzt
ersetzt das allerdings nicht wie gerade
gesagt kann es vorkommen dass bösartiger
krebs von der ki als harmlos eingestuft
wird
wenn ihr euch also nicht sicher seid
dann geht bitte auf jeden fall zu einem
richtigen hautarzt
ibm watson ist wohl eine der
bekanntesten und geheimsten k s
überhaupt watson gewinns quizshows tritt
in werbekampagnen auf und soll krebs
besiegen das war zumindest die
kampfansage von ibm
denn kaum ein krebs fall gleicht dem
anderen es gibt hunderte faktoren die
bei der entscheidung über die richtige
therapie eine rolle spielen
während die chemotherapie für den einen
patienten genau das richtige ist versagt
sie beim nächsten hier soll watson vor
oncology den ärzten unter die arme
greifen
der algorithmus hat das wissen aus
hunderten lehrbüchern studien und echten
fällen verinnerlicht und vergleicht
dieses mit den daten des aktuellen falls
daraus erstellt watson dann einen
therapievorschlag und das stand mitte
2018 schon für 13 krebsarten und in
weltweit 230 krankenhäusern
doch leider scheint das noch nicht immer
alles so gut zu klappen
der leiter der krebs abteilung eines
kopenhagener krankenhauses kritisierte
das programm letztes jahr
würde man den anweisungen watsons folgen
dann könnten patienten sterben
so hatte watson angeblich empfohlen
einem 65 jährigen patienten mit
blutungen ein medikament zu verabreichen
dass bei blutungen tödlich sein könnte
die abteilung in kopenhagen stoppte das
watson experiment ibm entgegnete dass
der patient nicht ideal gewesen sei und
nur ein test war
experten vermuten dass watson zu wenig
daten bekommen hat um wirklich
verlässlich zu sein
für eierstockkrebs zum beispiel gab es
nur 106 fälle
dabei wären mehrere tausend fälle gut um
eine solide basis an referenzen zu
schaffen um dem mangel an daten entgegen
zu steuern haben onkologen von ibm
angeblich fallbeispiele erfunden und den
datensätzen beigefügt der einsatz
sogenannter synthetischer daten ist zwar
nicht unüblich die auswirkungen
allerdings noch kaum erforscht ob watson
wirklich krebs besiegen kann ist also
fraglich aber deswegen sollte man ki
noch nicht abschreiben
vermutlich arbeiten andere unternehmen
schon an ihren k s die die daten eines
patienten auswerten und den behandelnden
arzt unterstützen können welche
medikamente wie miteinander
wechselwirken und welche vorgeschichte
ein patient hat kann sich ein mensch
alleine kaum merkbar schon gar nicht
wenn ein arzt dutzende patienten
gleichzeitig behandelt
in dieser daten getriebenen umgebung
kann man algorithmen wunderbar einsetzen
bei dem stichwort klingelt doch was
daten wer bekommt die eigentlich auf
welchem server werden sie verarbeitet
und was passiert wenn sie in die
falschen hände geraten
smart watch ist können heute schon alle
möglichen gesundheitsdaten sammeln
auswerten und im notfall sogar alarm
schlagen auf diese weise können
krankheiten möglicherweise verhindert
werden bevor sie überhaupt ausbrechen
aber ich bin mir sicher dass ich meine
krankenkasse auch dafür interessiert wie
oft ich zum sport gehe oder ob sich mein
blutzucker in den letzten tagen erhöht
hat wenn ich statt joggen zu gehen
netflix gucke und chips essen könnte
sich in zukunft meint
krankenkassenbeitrag erhöhen
das krankheitsrisiko ist ja gestiegen
nur wer fit bleibt zahlt weniger geld
klingt utopisch ist aber gar nicht mal
so weit entfernt und man muss sich auch
fragen welche interessen die künstlichen
intelligenzen selber vertreten
ob gut oder böse ist habe ich mich ja
schon in einem vorherigen video gefragt
daran habe ich erklärt dass ki immer
auch durch die programmierer und die
datensätze die er gefüttert werden
beeinflusst wird ein pharmakonzern hat
natürlich ein gewisses interesse daran
dass die calli häufiger mal die
krankheit diagnostiziert für die der
konzern ein medikament hat ein
krankenhaus operiert lieber einmal zu
viel als einmal zu wenig dementsprechend
könnte ibm mehr software lizenzen von
watson verkaufen wenn diese häufiger den
griff zum skalpell empfiehlt ein
interessenskonflikt über meinen letzten
punkt kann man streiten aber ich
behaupte ki fehlt intuition ein
algorithmus markt zwar alle daten über
einen patienten haben aber wie sich
dieser patient gibt das kann zumindest
aktuell nur der arzt oder die ärztin
wahrnehmung lud mich ein patient
vielleicht an weil ihm etwas peinlich
ist das passiert erstaunlich oft ja klar
benutze ich regelmäßig zahnseide
eine kaputte das erst mal glauben meiner
meinung nach werden ärztinnen und ärzte
also so schnell nicht ersetzt vielmehr
werden sie von intelligenter software
unterstützt das sorgt für besseren
diagnosen gesündere menschen und
hoffentlich weniger wartezeiten beim
arzt oder was meint ihr könntet ihr euch
vorstellen nur vom handy therapie zu
werden
kamera auf die stelle halten die wehtut
und das passende medikament wird schnell
patrone geliefert schreibt eure meinung
dazu gerne mal unten in die kommentare
ich bin sehr gespannt was jetzt zu
künstlicher intelligenz in der medizin
sagt vielen dank an wissenschaft im
dialog und das bundesministerium für
bildung und forschung für die
unterstützung meiner serie zum thema ki
im wissenschaftsjahr 2009 10
wie immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]